in the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion from May 14th, on which we commemorate the Holy
Marjorie Isidore of Heos.
On the 14th of the month we celebrate the memory of the Holy Marjorie Isidore of Heos.
A native of Alexandria, St. Isidore was lieutenant in the Roman army during the reign of Decius
in the year 250.
Having gone to the island of Heos as part of the fleet commanded by a certain numerias, he
was denounced as a Christian by the Centurion Julius.
When brought before the admiral, he proudly declared that he was a worshiper of Jesus Christ,
the one unique and only true God become man for our salvation.
His admins stretched out on the ground, tied to four stakes and beaten with a knuckled
whip by his men.
They then threw him into a furnace from which he emerged unscathed.
His own father was a hardened pagan, and arriving from Egypt during these proceedings asked
to undertake Isidore's subjection himself.
As his arguments had no effect, a fact that transformed nature's bond into an implacable
hatred, he had his son tied behind wild horses and dragged along the ground for a great distance,
after which the head of Christ's holy athlete was cut off.
His body was thrown into a ravine to be devoured by vultures, but a devout woman called
Maropeia managed to evade the guards' surveillance and retrieved his holy remains in order to give
them worthy burial.
A rested, tortured, and thrown into prison, she received there a vision of Saint Isidore
in which he was surrounded by a radiant light and an angelic choir singing the Trisagion.
He said to her, Peace be with you.
You are about to receive the crown God has reserved for you.
At these words, Saint Maropeia gave her soul into God's hands, and the dungeon was filled
with a fragrance perfume.
She was then buried beside Saint Isidore, who was soon venerated as the patron of the island
of Kios, and by the entire Mediterranean basin as the protector of sailors.
Through the prayers of our Holy Fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and
save us.